اسواق هجرت لفظت بضاعتها وانفض الناس من
حولها استهداف الاسواق في ولايه دارفور
جلي هنا حرب شلت الاسواق وقتلت الروح فيها
لكن روح التجاره لا تموت افترش اصحاب
المحلات ما تبقى من صالح بضاعتهم هنا
اختلقوا سوقا اخر فلا بد للرزق ان يسري
وان كان في خضم الحرب
ما حرق بعد الصوب
والان نهنا لجان للسوق عشان نقدر نطلع
يومياتنا باي صوره من الصور
مدينه الجنينه عانت الامرين حرب من جهه
واشتباكات بين القبائل ايضا عمليات نهب
وحرق افقدت التجار هنا باب رزقهم الوحيد
للالهنا الميزات بتختلف ماذا الاماكن
الثانيه لانه بتاخد طابع اخر تابع بث
ات او تابع قبل
مواطن وانا كبير وفقدت عدد كبير من
الارواح
خسرت المدينه من ابنائها ما يقارب 100 شخص
على الاقل احداث تتوالى فيها الخسارات وسط
مخاوف من عنف قد يستمر طويلا غيداء السالم
العربيه لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات